I think we just need a little place to get away and have a nice time.
Breaking news about the Ladies lounge in Mona.
They've been ordered by the Tazi Tribunal
to allow men into the ladies lounge.
I thought men were supposed to be rational beings
because that doesn't sound like it makes any logical sense to me.
Further to this, they've gone into a lot of detail about how offensive,
um, the performance art around the case was
whereby like
all the female supporters dressed in suits
and danced their way out of courtroom.
And to that, I just think they need to loosen up,
relax and develop a proper sense of humour.
It'll be interesting to see how this case develops
and if there's an appeal. Um,
I think they're gonna close down the ladies lounge.
Um,
artist just said it's a ladies lunch,
so we're not gonna let men into it.
We're gonna have to close the artwork down.
Um, the judge also said that like they,
men haven't been able to experience the artwork,
which have already gone into in a prior video.
Men absolutely have been able to experience the artwork
by experiencing the exclusion from a space
that they've paid equal money for,
which is what women experience and have been experiencing
time and memorial. So
it would be very interesting to see if there is an appeal
on the basis of equity and on the basis of the historical context, um,
of The way that women have been historically
exploded from these type of male clubs. More to come.